hi guys this is len from singapore and
you are watching ochotro tv
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can get uh
oh oh now land 94 with a launch
rage but you're gonna survive this
oh my god loads of falling out okay
[Music]
oh do not step up my foot
and you know i think lanai kind of
nullified um a lot of his opportunities
but by stepping left side walking class
and not getting hit by those gods
while you were explaining
[Music]
another one all right we're going to get
a big wall combo once again and one more
combo is always trying to take
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh they trade and land picks it up
[Music]
look in the red oh wow
[Music]
and that's
what
fossil wanted to do
[Music]
[Music]
oh the movement for land 94 on this play
though oh wow is sidestepping left side
walking
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
himself tried to go for it
oh nice if he can make if he doesn't
drop this combo
can he get my goodness
sure
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
ready
[Music]
you